bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono parigi e io ci siamo
un gioco che mi ha fatto veramente
crescere la rogna dentro il fegato o
registrato voglio regista già morto
sono partito che son morto sono su perso
oltre gatti un gioco dove si muore
ok mi stavo permettere a giocare per i
cazzi miei poi ho detto va bene registra
una partita e volete porca vacca ribotta
bene non è andata neanche troppo ma le
sue uscite sono arrivato anche ad un box
che questo qui in tutta la mia scarsità
proverò a batterlo già solo per arrivare
alla sostanza mi prenderò tante di
quelle botte in faccia che la metà basta
tipo questa aveva mancato
ok questa è la canzone ghost ragazzi ci
siamo provo proverò a batterlo ma ci ha
già provato due volte non ci sono
riuscito quindi provo la terza ciao
bell'uomo tela infini.to tale capra
antico la roba lì ecco sporca di posa
laida
porca vacca conto di foto olio tolto un
quarto diritto sono dato il meglio del
solito per adesso speriamo che durante
il viso facciano cosa decente ti può
fare un gameplay educare buratti
maledetto tra il problema letto gioco
che quando sicuri non fa in tempo a
curarti ma scemo
queste cose soleggiato ai diventato più
cazzuto ed ironica sta facendo chiesto
fiato e la madonna non ero mai arrivato
fino a questo punto arca vacca 6 st
duomo ma fa già un'ora difficile e morte
morta e morta la copia ai ha fatto leva
aiuto aiuto aiuto e le giocate più in
quanto è la vita dove erano loro che
vinco no
ma una cosa l'ho colta soffrivo quanta
vita avevo nono anno basta a creare
copie rotocalcio loro soccorso con
quanta vita ora devo vincere per forza
perché sono sopravvissuto un troppa poca
vita mi ricapiterà ma devo fare fuori la
coppia ragazzi ci vincola bravo bravo
pippo stato bravissimo qua perfetto
occhio non ti fa il peccato noti o da
indagare il cazzo scoppiati di nuovo
meno noto nudo posso credere.ho
incredibile non ci avrei mai creduto
minchia che ora 100.000 lei si chiama
dato questo grosso sto coso porca vacca
quanto e potente era gesù ma che storia
non mi chiama lo voglio troppo usare
bellissimo posso usarlo con questa sia
affetto il prosciutto anche roba tipo
questa è rega che è un po grande questo
gol
porca dr pirati che valve
ma il raduno degli arci mali o qual cosa
sia giusto in mano ai marie n'gbo sulla
stessa roba questo amico al culoso già
vabbè ragazzi provo è mite un calcio gli
ha dato mai così ai la motoretta per
quanto mi sta togliendo 888 it in cui
l'occhio è piatta maledetto perfetto un
andato mancava altro che ricorda in
regola ma non ha fatto niente
si no libro di stare calma stai calmo
caffè aragon motivo di un occhio ai sa
che non è che inizi la tua ata diventati
potente ma ammazzati
no no no no no gravissimo bravo o regala
una misura tutti bene a studiarla sono
detto perché sto registrando lance
doppie di drang brace gesù salve segue
porca vacca
porca [ __ ] cattura arca vacca magnete
devo schivarli che lo fa chi portivo ma
dotato cioè una lancia sulla lancia
conficcata nello stomaco bellissimo
succhia madonna tre sono porca [ __ ] ci
manca tori chi di voi la palla o hard
quando hai a porta tutto a posto
perfetto un'andata arco potente da
ammazzadraghi mamma stato sorella da un
metro dall'arco e mi raccomando o di
quello è questo tema porca vacca un
bonavena ascensore normale no del
girarti la torre va bene l'altro preciso
è meraviglioso bottone una fiaschetta
l'ultima governo un genio
sono rimasta ben 30 mila punti cosa c'è
qua sopra ragazzi top scalinata vita
tanto di battaglia di borse però non ne
posso battere due giorno battuto 1
miracolo no non ce l'ha data room
oddio tipo prince of persia sta roba per
girare in gola torre la madonna mi porti
a milano grazie altro che la m rega
secondo me appena entrano dentro mi mi
fanno sconfiggere gesù ha troppo
non sapevo come chiamare il mio
personaggio l'ho chiamato lori più so
perché non c'è fantasia prova provata
equipaggiare la spada nuova per vedere
come questa qua in italia le manate
forti
non so che sono in grado di usarlo il
software questo da dove vi chi è uscito
quest'uomo
faccio lo gap da fava minchia
mi sa che è un po forte questo spalla
l'ho trovato il tuo e visita ne va bene
allora è affisso mega portone non so se
si apre ma se ti apre chiusa da qualche
marchingegno va bene hai aperto qua ok
perfetto permesso eccolo lì con te
pareva che non ci fosse bot
un attimo ma cosa cazzo al questo non si
apre la quale era la porta bhutan rock
mi servirebbe la porta alle lobby ha
prima volta fa mi aprì la porta di
capannori ha portato a madrid sta minkia
quanto valutata zona dalle dio
lei non è tanto simpatico via io vorrei
uscire posso uscire mi fate uscire
fatemici fammi uscire aia all'urto è
uscito è precaria d'orto è presente che
i cani addosso c
no non si è cagato non si è cagato per
niente vacanze voluta per sorridere la
madonna ma è forte questi è fortissimo
immagino ucciso mi farà giuro
ma porca [ __ ] metà vino coltivatore
qualche volta è questa non re spa una
etf pareva ma non mi ha dato anche tanti
punti come possibile allora la gala
missione adesso è questa proviamo
entrare nella stanza del boss per vedere
com'è stato non saprò mai a battere
l'odioso rubato l'inchino da me stesso
ma non penso che già un miracolo che
hanno fatto un invito figurazione fatto
due fatica a trigoria
ok non so è questa la stanza di un boss
non so come fammi vedere quanto sei
bello altri che devono fare degli dei
salve lei è molto bello sa ripararmi co
dietro non mi posso riparare qua dietro
venitem partiti benissimo ai ha in cassa
rob è fortissima buffa ma quanto mi fa
cagare addosso questo è che forse ci
arrivo arrivo ci ha rivolto l'aveva
inavvicinabile cometa pck sul d'amico
pregio
ragazzi ma come faccio a batterlo
impossibile ben di dio e faty colpire
per questo e diego sono nel video e non
faccio la figura fortana tua mamma
ricattato s'è incazzato un po rega
la prima andata non andava bene figura
di moto minchia dietro il muro migliaia
sono mosso lo svenuto venuto dal nulla
va bene se non ho capito ma va bene ho
battuto vostri forti e questo non saprò
mai il cielo provare quelle venti volte
almeno registro 20 volte cinque anni lui
scappa via la scelta teneva decide
occhio eccoli incazzato ma io ci vado lo
stesso perché non ho paura senza paura
va bene non ho sbagliato ford cavallo
sbagliato [ __ ] vabbè lo ha battuto
uno di posti nel vito 15 aveva già bene
così impossibile
gli faccio solo presente che io questo
joystick qui l'ho tirato già due tre
volte da quando ho iniziato a giocare al
suo gioco però qualora fare un contratto
di un po diverso quindi fatemi sapere se
vi è piaciuto diciamo che questo è uno
dei giochi che faccio io che non
registro mai gioco per i gatti miei però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io con
chrome il episodi e cosa mi piace
[Musica]
m
il
[Musica]
no